yeah remember this is the losers
quarters portion of the bracket right
here one of these players is going home
and again I mean well will pretty much
say it throughout the entirety of this
bracket some somebody had to lose a
survey I mean you know party was
starting out in matically you already
got it Aloha felt very very close to Gus
range at this point Dark Legacy is
currently active three or four gets walk
and I mean the pressure continues for
party well Pete's got him at the wall
but there it is the jumping cake I loved
that party wolf just sat down right you
didn't want to have to deal with the
possibility of a leaflet mix-up and you
know he didn't and then he got the round
for it that may have actually been one
of the biggest decisions that got him
out yeah he definitely doesn't one of my
welding cords the hop plus two frames
right and he's doing such a good job of
spacing those out pretty much exactly
and this is one of the few times I've
seen link [ __ ] do not get just frame a
PA every single [ __ ] all right that's
gotta be a slight be those into the base
hold three a four is gonna put a little
bit of pressure on in the life others
are about even and they both have the
same amount of meter as well make it the
knockdown here what's it is pokin he's
got guts okay no we're barely hanging on
but he's gonna take some life from that
that's a real nice thing for party wolf
it not only he's gonna put him in a
check situation because of his health
and there's the may actually check
yeah you know much like Siegfried I feel
like he's very strongly behind the
mixture screams of goes to avenge but
not to date a full charge out of it on
the baseball rush West's disadvantage
right there and damage off encrusted
situations but they're 56 Oh
drive-by I like how he waited long
enough that it I corrected to wear off
some people have privileged some thought
I'm just being honest transitioning into
the cheap old able to put party will fit
about oh yeah trying to catch him
pecking right there then we'll see yeah
but it doesn't car break oh but he's for
that a fly come out so all yeah that
could have been a terrible situation
that almost put it as an auto break
possible better than that's gonna do
that
a lot of damage over here the mix-up is
you know okay
well having a bar and better it is the
low as link cores from 200 in terms of
rounds bringing it all the way back with
his composure you know you got the dark
legacy on deck in real life to pre-match
same stage run it back let's get it
going it's gonna knock him down I mean
you never know you might be you might
just let it risk you don't even know you
don't know me don't hit right there was
able to catch them on the backside it
looks like yeah up a nine-foot party
won't be privy for a lot one flag
hostile of kin Oh there'd be a plus B
st. chip damage from bubble all went
under the baseball actually with under
allowing him to get the extra sack and
all the damage on the sees this may
actually you want to go situation where
he may I get double dog like
hands off me before all the stunts right
next to the wall oh my goodness keep
going okay I wasn't sure if that was
actually gonna have a penny but it did
here we go two rounds up the best points
for links like those welcome bring it
back you know he's got two barns and
this is a pretty much the exact same
situation all right yeah anything is
possible
you know I need a stick free place from
behind a lot better than ninety so we're
taping the games right yeah oh what a
great way to punish right there and Link
[ __ ] that's gonna do it you take him
down party wolf right there his reign
but goddamn party wolf doing so so well
what a massive run starting from 10:00
a.m. today making that entire LCQ run
winning LCQ and then coming into this
tournaments well yeah absolutely give it
up for party wolf eyes please give it up
for party wolf take it down taking down
strong players like sane
Evo champion you Tonto just incredible
only Korres is going to be the one
moving on though and party wolf well